and the nominees for Best Original Song
are we belong together from Toy Story 3
music and lyrics by Randy Newman I see
the light from tangled
music by Alan Menken lyric by Glenn
Slater if I rise from 127 hours
music by ar-rahman lyric by title in
Rollo Armstrong coming home from Country
Strong music and lyric by Tom Douglas
Troy Burgess and Hilary Lindsay and the
Oscar goes to Randy Newman for we belong
together
this is the second Academy Award and
twentieth nomination for Randy Newman
his first Oscar nominations were for
Best Original Song and Best Original
Score for ragtime
what's the mic looks like a mic well at
the I'm very grateful for this and
surprised my percentages aren't great
I've been nominated 20 times this the
second time alone at the academy at the
lunch they have from the nominees where
they have like a Randy Newman chicken by
this time the mr. mu sure said that it's
not really good television to take a
list out of your pocket and thank a lot
of people cause it's not my style anyway
but I it is in this case I mean you have
work for Pixar doing the six pictures
I've done on this one Lee Unkrich
and and work with Mitchell froom Chris
Montana at Disney I just have to thank
these people I don't want to I want to
be good television so badly as you can
see I I've been on the show any number
of times that I've slowed it down almost
every time no wonder they only nominate
four songs there's not what what about
cinematographers does five you know you
can find a fifth song from someone but
how was it it I think it mighta beat me
anyway I thank you all very much for
this Academy's been enormous ly kind to
me asked as the music branch and I love
you all thank you very much
you